we're told that felipe feeds his dog the
same amount every day from a large bag
of dog food
two weeks after initially opening the
bag he decided to start weighing how
much food remained in the bag on a
weekly basis here's some of his data so
we see after 14 days there's 14
kilograms remaining then after another
seven days passed by so now we're 21
days from the beginning there's only 10
and a half kilograms left then after 28
days there are seven kilograms left
all right so we're going to try to use
this data to start answering some
interesting questions and maybe we'll
also try to visualize it with a graph so
the first thing that we might try to
tackle is well how much how much food
was in the bag to begin with if we
assume that he's using the same amount
of food every week so pause this video
and see if you can figure that out how
much food was in the bag to begin with
if we assume that felipe is feeding his
dog the same amount every week
okay now there's several ways to do this
but to help us visualize this let me see
if i can graph the data that we have and
then see what would happen
as we approach the beginning of
this of what's going on here the dog
feeding and maybe as we go to the end as
well
so let's see this is my x-axis this is
my y-axis i'm going to make x-axis
measure the passage of the days so
number of days on the x-axis and on the
y-axis i'm going to measure i'm going to
measure food
remaining
and that is in kilograms and let's see
it looks like maybe if my scale goes up
to let's make this
5
10
[Music]
15
20
and then 25 i can make a little higher
25 i think this will be sufficient
and then we want to go up to 28 days and
it looks like they're measuring
everything on a weekly basis so let's
say that this is
7
14
21 and then 28 and they gave us some
data points
so
after 14 days there's 14 kilograms
remaining so 14 days there's 14
kilograms remaining right over there
after 21 days there's 10 and a half
kilograms remaining
21 days
10 and a half is right about there
after 28 days there's seven
kilograms remaining so after 28 days 7
kilograms
and we're assuming the rate of the dog
food usage is the same that he's feeding
his dog the same amount every week and
so this would describe a line that the
rate is going to be the slope of that
line and then if we can plot this line
if we know where that line intersects
the x and y axes we might be able to
figure out some other things so actually
let me draw a line here let me see if i
can use this little line tool to connect
the dots
in a reasonable
in a reasonable way
so let's say it looks something
like that that's our line
that will describe how quickly he is
using his dog food so let me make sure
that this dot is should be on the line
as well
now let's try to answer that first
question and think about how we might do
it how much food was in the bag to begin
with so what point here represents how
much food was in the bag to begin with
well that's the amount of food remaining
at day zero at the beginning of this so
that would be this point right over here
would describe how much food was in the
bag to begin with this would be the
y-intercept
y-intercept is when our x-value is equal
to zero what is our y-value and when we
just look at the graph it looks like
it's a little bit over 20 but we could
find the exact value by thinking about
the slope which is thinking about the
rate at which the dog food is being
depleted we can see that every
week
every week that goes by or every seven
days that goes by it looks like we use
three and a half kilograms or another
way to think about it every two weeks it
looks like we use an entire kilogram
so let me put it this way when we go
plus 14 days
plus 14 days it looks like
we use up
or the food remaining goes down by
a
goes down every two weeks are it goes
down by seven kilograms
seven kilograms negative 7 kilograms
so if we want to figure out this exact
value we just have to reverse things if
we are going back 14 days
then we're going to go up 7 kilograms
so if we were at 14 up 7 kilograms this
right over here is the point 0 comma 21.
so how much food did felipe start with
in the bag 21 kilograms and we got that
from the y-intercept
now another question is how much is
felipe feeding his dog every day pause
this video and see if you can figure
that out
well we know every 14 days he's feeding
the dog seven kilograms
so one way to think about it is
and we're really looking at the slope
here to figure out the rate at which
he's feeding his dog so the slope
is equal to our change in the y so
negative seven kilograms every our
change in the x every 14 days
and so 7 over 14 is the same thing as
one half so this is equal to negative
one half of a kilogram
per day
so this tells us every day the food
remaining is going down half a kilogram
so that means he's feeding his dog
assuming his dog is is eating the food
and finishing it that his dog is eating
half a kilogram a day
and if we wanted to ask another question
how many days will the bag last how
would you think about that and we know
it's going to be out here someplace if
we just continue that line
because this point right over here where
our line intersects the x-axis that
would be our x-intercept
that is the x value when our y value is
zero and our y is the amount of food
remaining so we want to know what what
day do we have no food remaining and we
could try to estimate it or we could
figure out it exactly we know that every
14 days we use up seven kilograms so
if we are at 7 as we are right over here
and we go 14 days in the future we
should use up the remaining the
remaining contents of the bag so plus 14
days
we're going to use up the remaining 7
kilograms
and so this should happen 14 days after
the 28th day so this is going to be the
42nd day